let's talk about the seven warning signs
of a b12
deficiency
now b12 is
it's kind of an important vitamin it's
involved in making dna
myelin sheath which is the coating
around the nerves
like in this wire
if we were to take off the outside
coating
okay that would
potentially short circuit
same thing that happens in your nervous
system we'll cover that
also b12 is involved in making things
like red blood cells which is kind of
important so b12 is very very vital and
it's important for you to know these
symptoms because there's usually like
seven big symptoms that are not
necessarily related but it's important
to identify them because
one thing about a b12 deficiency is that
if you're deficient
you can actually experience irreversible
damage to your nervous system so we're
going to cover all that
but i first wanted to mention uh one
thing about the type of b12
there's two types there's a natural
version of e12 and there's a synthetic
version of course i'm going to recommend
always take the natural version and the
natural version is called
methylcobolamine that's the one that you
want to take in your supplements
the other one that's synthetic that i
don't recommend
is called
cyanocobolamine i recommend you avoid
that one because it's synthetic now
what's kind of interesting about b12 is
that
the main reason why people
are deficient
is not necessarily that they're not
eating foods with b12 it has to do with
malabsorption or just they're not able
to absorb b12 the b12 absorption is very
complex there's a lot of things that are
happening
from the stomach to the small intestine
and the absorption
your body needs this carrier
transportation protein to help you
absorb it it's called intrinsic factor
and if you don't have it
or you have an autoimmune disease you
can get something called pernicious
anemia which i don't want to get into
that but it's a another problem because
you have an autoimmune disease to
this thing called intrinsic factor or
the cells that make it which is in the
stomach but the point is that
the reason why people can't absorb it is
because they either have some type of
atrophy of the stomach
or they're lacking hydrochloric acid
or they have gastritis or they have an
ulcer of the stomach or they have celiac
or crohn's or irritable bowel syndrome
further into the digestive tract so any
of these conditions
can severely
block the absorption of b12
and so many people have those issues and
then they become deficient in b12
because they don't connect the dots they
don't understand to absorb b12 you need
a good digestive system and b12 is very
common in the elderly about 20 percent
of everyone over the age of 60
has a b12 deficiency now personally i
think that the big reason is the lack of
hydrochloric acid uh either production
or they just don't have the
the concentration of acid in their
stomach it's as we get older we lose the
acidity of our stomach and also the
ability to absorb b12 and so this is
another reason why i recommend
everyone over the age of
55 start taking
things to acidify the stomach like
retain hydrochloride like apple cider
vinegar
that alone will just start increasing
b12 and the person will start having
more and more energy now we don't need
much b12 we need it in micrograms not
milligrams
so an average person would need anywhere
between 2.4 micrograms to 2.8 micrograms
very small amounts but when you
buy a b complex
product which you have to be careful
because most of them are synthetic when
looking the label will say like a
thousand to five thousand percent more
b12 than your body really needs
so there is some problems with excessive
amounts of b12
but typically with b12 i recommend you
get it from the diet it's very easy to
get from the diet so let's talk about
the foods that you can get b12 of course
animal liver okay like beef liver you're
gonna get a lot of b12 or kidney okay
personally i don't like liver or kidney
but you can get it as a supplement if
you're anemic
clams and other seafood sardines
beef okay
other meats chicken
fish
some fermented products like kimchi
sauerkraut might have b12 also
fermented dairy as in cheese has some
b12 insects uh have b12 so if you ever
get the hankering for
you know crunching on some insects
you'll get some b12 and also nutritional
yeast but
not really because when you buy
nutritional yeast
a lot of times it just says it's
fortified and so they add a synthetic
b12 to it and i don't recommend that i
do have a nutritional yeast product and
i do add one thing to it and that is the
natural version of b12
methylcobolamine
but many nutritional yeast products are
fortified and anytime it's fortified
they always use synthetics and it's from
usually petroleum and so i don't
recommend fortified nutritional yeast
now another interesting thing about b12
especially if someone's a vegan or
vegetarian is that
they don't eat animal products so
usually they're going to be deficient
unless they take b12
and when i had my wheatgrass juice
powder product evaluated
i had them test b12 just to see if there
was any b12 in it and i was actually
shocked to find that it was double what
uh our requirements were and i thought
it was a mistake but where that b12 is
coming from is the bacteria living in
that nutritional yeast product because
we don't use high heats and it's done on
temperatures of
nothing greater than 106. so
apparently microorganisms that live
around plants can make b12
all right let's go through these
symptoms there's seven of them okay
number one
pale skin now why would you experience
pale skin well because you're not able
to make red blood cells and you're not
getting the oxygen and so your body is
starving of oxygen and you're looking a
rather
pale like you would see in someone
that's anemic now sometimes your skin
might be a little yellow or jaundice
because the red blood cells are fragile
and the byproducts can then create
that appearance all right number two
you're going to feel constant fatigue
weak you're always going to be sleepy
and drowsy no matter how much you try to
get some sleep that is because without
oxygen your metabolism can't work you're
just going to be always tired all right
number three
mouth problems you may have ulcers in
your mouth
you may have a shiny swollen red tongue
why because the tongue is not able to
get oxygen and it's swelling up all
right number four
cognitive issues so without b12 you can
be very very depressed
severely depressed you can have anxiety
you can have memory problems you can
have paranoia you can be delusional your
thinking really gets thrown off if you
don't have enough b12 because both the
brain and the nervous system need b12
when the brain doesn't get oxygen it
just cannot work
all right number five and this does
relate to the cognitive function but
nerves okay
if you're deficient in b12
you're not going to be able to make
myelin myelin is the coating around the
nerves like they talked about and so if
you can't make this myelin
you're going to start getting a short
circuiting problem in the nervous system
and that's going to show up as
peripheral neuropathy now what's the
definition of peripheral well the outer
edges of something right and neuropathy
neural nerve
pathy means disorder so it's a disorder
of the nerve on the outer edges of your
body like your toes or the bottom of
your feet or your fingertips in practice
i've usually noticed that it was mainly
in the feet not the hands but it can
occur in the hands
so we have peripheral neuropathy now if
you're
very severely deficient in b12
you can experience irreversible nerve
damage and you can be in severe pain i
mean it's it's really really bad because
it's irreversible so what are you gonna
do so this is why i'm doing this video
so you can catch it before it creates
irreversible nerve damage
i mean in practice i had a guy come in
with this problem okay it was so bad he
really wanted to commit suicide because
it got to the point where he just
couldn't get rid of the pain and so now
he basically is forced to live on
medication permanently which is terrible
all right number six blurred vision why
because what helps you see is the retina
the retina is neurological tissue that
is in your eye and it goes directly back
into your brain and if that's affected
you're not going to be able to see that
well so one symptom would be noticing
that you you know your vision is
worsening and you need glasses for no
reason suspect a potential b12
deficiency all right and the last
symptom would be a fast
pulse rate now why would the heart start
increasing its beats
well that is because
you can't make red blood cells so that
means you're not going to have oxygen
and the body has to compensate for a
lack of oxygen by increasing the rate or
speed at which your heart pushes
blood through the body so anyway i just
really want to increase your awareness
on b12
now that you understand b12 i think the
next most important vitamin to
understand would be vitamin b1
and check that out i put it right here